dos equipos de béisbol comparan el
número de fans que asistieron a sus
juegos más recientes la asistencia al
juego de los 'diablos rojos' fue de 12
mil 896 fans la asistencia al juego de
los tigres fue de 12.901 fans cuál de
los equipos tuvo más fans en su juego
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta vamos
a resolverlos juntos nos dicen que los
diablos rojos tuvieron 12 mil 896 fans
en su juego más reciente y hay una razón
por la que estoy escribiendo esto con
mucho espacio y al juego de los tigres
asistieron 12 mil 901 fans a mí me gusta
comparar los números observando primero
la posición de valor más significativa y
compararlos en ambas cantidades tenemos
10.000 así que en esta posición de valor
tenemos el mismo número de vemos la
siguiente posición y tenemos la misma
cantidad dos millares pero cuando
llegamos a las centenas noten que los
tigres tienen más centenas que los
'diablos rojos' no importa qué cantidad
tengamos
escenas y en las unidades si aquí se
tienen más centenas quiere decir que los
tigres tienen una mayor cantidad de fans
nuevamente analizamos cada una de las
posiciones de valor comenzando con la
más significativa y vimos que aquí
tenemos la misma cantidad
luego comparamos la siguiente posición
de valor en donde también tenemos la
misma cantidad 2 y 2 después pasamos a
la siguiente posición de valor y aquí si
encontramos una diferencia en las
centenas y vimos que el número de los
tigres es más grande por lo que sé que
los tigres tienen más fans que los
'diablos rojos' 12.901 es mayor y me
acuerdo muy bien de este signo porque
abre hacia dónde está la cantidad más
grande por lo que esto es mayor que 12
mil 896 incluso podríamos contarlos
tenemos 12 mil 896 12 mil 897 12 mil 898
12 mil 899 12 mil 900 y 12 mil 901
hagamos otro ejemplo la tabla muestra el
peso de varios animales del zoológico
ordena a los animales del más ligero al
más pesado el animal más ligero debe
estar al principio de la lista
resolvamos esto de la misma manera pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
primero por su cuenta
veamos las cantidades que tenemos aquí y
podemos notar que el peso de un animal
tiene más dígitos el del oso polar
notamos que hay un uno en la posición de
los millares en cambio el peso de la
jirafa y el cocodrilo no tienen ningún
número en esta posición así que de
inmediato podemos ver que el que pesa
más es el oso polar pero nos piden
primero poner el animal más ligero al
principio de la lista veamos las
siguientes cantidades el peso de la
jirafa y el peso del cocodrilo tienen el
mismo número en la posición de las
centenas tienen un 9 así que tenemos que
seguir comparando la siguiente posición
de valor para ver cuál es la diferencia
entre estos pesos en la posición de las
decenas también tenemos un 9 así que
tenemos que ir a la siguiente posición
de las unidades para compararlos
y si vemos que el peso de la jirafa
tiene un 3 en las unidades y el del
cocodrilo tiene un 8 por lo que la
jirafa pesa menos que el cocodrilo 3 es
menor que 8 la jirafa tiene el menor
número de unidades y tenemos el mismo
número de decenas y de centenas en el
peso de la jirafa y el cocodrilo luego
sigue el cocodrilo y hasta el final
viene el oso polar
y nuevamente vemos las posiciones de
valor y las comparamos el peso del oso
polar tiene una posición de valor mayor
que el peso de la jirafa y el cocodrilo
viendo los pesos restantes notamos que
las centenas del peso de la jirafa y del
cocodrilo son las mismas 9 centenas así
que tenemos que analizar la siguiente
posición de valor que es de las decenas
y nos encontramos que también tienen el
mismo número 9 y 9 finalmente pasamos a
la siguiente posición de valor que son
las unidades y aquí ya encontramos una
diferencia el peso de la jirafa tiene 3
unidades y el peso del cocodrilo tiene 8
unidades por lo que la jirafa pesa menos
que el cocodrilo resolvamos otro
problema la siguiente tabla muestra las
elevaciones de 3 montañas en américa del
norte
anna trata de adivinar la elevación de
la montaña university peak ella sabe que
es más alta que el monte massive pero no
tan alta como el monte albers ton pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
ustedes solos
la cantidad que estamos buscando es
mayor que cuatro mil 398 pero menor que
cuatro mil 420 escribe en el espacio en
blanco la elevación que podría adivinar
anna sobre la montaña university peak
qué cantidad podríamos poner aquí que
fuera mayor que cuatro mil 398 una
posibilidad es agregar un 1 a la
elevación de monte massive que sería
4.399 esto cumple con las condiciones ya
que es más alta que el monte massive
pero es más pequeña que el monte
alverson sigue teniendo menos centenas
que el monte alverson así que lo podemos
escribir aquí 4.399 también pudimos
haber escrito cuatro mil cuatrocientos y
así sucesivamente hasta cuatro mil 419
todas estas cantidades cumplen estas
condiciones de ser mayores que la
elevación de monte massive pero menores
que la elevación de monte albert son así
que cualquiera de estas cantidades
serían respuestas aceptables